hey everyone this is Steve wintrop with
collider and we are here in the collider
Studio sponsored by Saratoga Springwater
thank you Saratoga Sundance is expensive
we need sponsors thank you uh and I'm
just gonna say I'm here with the cast of
divinity and the composer of divinity
and I want to say uh congratulations for
being part of Sundance thank you thank
you so much
um so listen uh the film has not
premiered yet I have not seen it yet but
I have seen footage I saw the trailer
the teaser trailer if you will and one
of the things that look like it looks
really cool and different and not what I
was expecting and I would imagine for
all of you guys this had to have been a
unique process like working on the film
so for all four of you can you sort of
talk about what Drew you to the script
what Drew you to the project
um for me I think it was really just the
opportunity to work with Eddie he is
such a mastermind in what he does and
we've all saw uh of one of my Vandal
Vandal I was gonna say Vault gosh Vandal
um that was amazing as well so
I just wanted to be a part of his his
art and his work
um and so when he asked me I was like oh
dude yeah absolutely
um well I had auditioned for a whole
different movie and then Eddie like
called me and he was like yeah let's do
it like I want you to be part of this
movie and like we were at his house like
trying to ride a bike like yeah no all
this crazy stuff and then one day he
just comes and he's like I have another
idea actually so I was like completely
um in the like mindset that I was gonna
do a different movie and then one day
Eddie just comes with like a whole
different script the whole different
mood boarding he's like let's just do
something else I was like
okay I mean I'm down I was I was totally
um prepared to do something else but
because of Eddie and like his vision I
was like listen where are you trying to
go let me just follow you
yeah absolutely I mean I think
um all of us were a fan of uh Eddie's
work and I think uh initially I received
the same script and I think Eddie wanted
us two together I don't know if yeah
people have noticed but like we're
pretty similar in many ways
um and I think that hopefully that
translates to the image I think
um you know it's it's these two uh
Brothers mysterious Brothers
um and I think that uh in the black and
white world and in the
tone of the story I think
what we were able to
put together hopefully comes together
um okay well hi
um I yes a fan of Eddie's work I met him
at a cannon he was just really sweet we
talked about a few
um projects and uh and then he talked
about this one and he was like hey do
you have some time to like come in and
shoot some [__] for us I was like [__]
yeah
um and um yeah I didn't get a script um
was not aware that there ever was a
script but then at some point I was like
okay but but anyway I'm gonna need you
to write me just like a little something
to work with so that we can like you
know because uh yeah I think sometimes
as actors you feel a little like trained
in that way of like do this do that know
your lines know this know your world um
and then this was exactly the opposite
of that
um and that was really fun it was a
really interesting experience I've never
done that before yeah I can't imagine
um what that's like but at the same time
like anyway I I would imagine when you
finally see the finished film you're
gonna it's gonna be an experience
so you have a pretty good resume when it
comes to music I'm going to say it like
that and I'm curious if someone has
actually never heard anything you've
done before what is the first thing you
want them listening to and why
probably man my first album I put out
was Cypress Hill first album just uh my
first album was Cypress Hill 91. that
was like our whole lives you know what I
mean our whole lives was that first
album everything we was doing everything
we was going through
how he was acting what was happening so
that would probably be it right there so
I want to do a follow-up how did you
actually get involved in doing you know
for this film well Eddie reached out for
me and um you know we was talking back
and forth for a minute and this is
something outside of my comfort zone so
it was a challenge you know to bring the
sound and this pulse to this
different world so I was like yeah I'm
up for this let's do it so if you don't
mind me asking like where did you start
in terms of did he give you some sort of
like in like you know did he give you
some parameters of what he was looking
for do you say you you do this and I'll
give you feedback no we talked we
watched the film a few times we talked
and then um he just let me have at it so
what what can you teach people about the
sound
um
it's Unique you know it was unique and
it was a challenge and it was fun and
you know it was something I don't want
to keep rehashing anything that I've
done in the past so for me to be have
the pleasure to be able to do this was
um definitely a challenge and I had a
good time making it man I'm gonna go
back to you guys
um a follow-up question similar to what
I just said uh for for all of you guys
if someone has actually never seen
anything you've done before what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
uh my first Sundance experience was
Kings of Summer um that'll always be
very memorable and it was a very uh
I was 18 years old it was the first uh
obviously Festival I went to with the
film that because uh it was sort of my
graduation from my childhood to I
wouldn't say a grown man but
a growner man growinger
um I did this movie that um that I liked
a lot called girl
um it was very fun the director was uh
great to work with and he wrote it as
well and I I love a script that is also
written by the director I always like
that
I would probably probably say a show
that I was on called claws
um that was like a huge moment and
experience for me and I think it was
like the final moment where
people took me serious and I was able to
really
um show myself as as an actor and in my
art and be creative
um so yeah
um I would say on my block
because I just think that the writing is
so impeccable like to like beyond the
acting I think the writing of that is
just like Timeless so like to get to be
part of something that I think is
sort of almost like this cult phenomenon
is is like a blessing uh I would I don't
know how long you guys actually Shot the
movie I don't know the specifics but
I'll say for for the four of you what
was one day on set that you were like I
don't know uh like circled you know in
terms of a challenging day on set or
something you were excited to film or if
you talk a little bit about the making
of the film because I see her smiles and
I know there are stories
I think we spent maybe a total of like a
month and a half filming part of that
was in Joshua Tree which we did a lot of
our work
we we had some uh interesting scenes we
I don't know if we want to like give
away what we did
um we had a very intimacy intimate scene
between all of us even if yeah tonight
girl that'll be fun at the premiere
yeah we had
an interesting crazy in a different way
yeah we were like yelling at each other
and things are happening I don't want to
give the movie away but it's intense
yeah honestly everything this was going
to be a bit um you know I was excited it
was one location one
um even though throughout the blocks of
shooting it ended up not being that but
I thought it was going to be you know
um nice because of that and then 120
degree weather is a factor in our
tattoos which cover our palms
um and sweat
and Jiu-Jitsu fighting you can imagine
how chaotic that can uh well did you
know that when you first signed on that
you'd be doing some of those things yeah
definitely but I think
um that we didn't consider the the
actual like temperatures
um and yeah I mean
yeah for sure it was too much oh he was
basically saying it's a [__] show
because makeup's going everywhere
and it's all hot and sweating everybody
feels like are you trying to say that
making movies is not as glamorous as
people think
did you have a thing oh I was I mean
yeah I had to like adult real quick I
went from like playing 14 to like
you'll see not 14.
maybe some crazy 14 year olds but there
was also this one day that um like we
had to do a scene where we eat
and usually you do scenes with foods and
movies and like you have a spit bucket
and you could but like Eddie just wants
to keep going you're also shooting on
film so it's like
it's not as easy to manipulate so like
we had to actually eat this food and I'm
just like so sensitive that like between
every cut I was like ready to throw up
and ready to die on this set but it was
it was like a lot of fun but it was like
the most intense turkey papaya turkey
but yeah but he wanted us to like eat
like animals like Monsters like with our
hands and it was just like yeah
I've spoken to a lot of actors about
eating scenes and it's like some I've
spoken to like I forget what someone
told me they ate like seven platefuls of
pasta oh Joel kinnamon when he was
filming yeah he's like he will eat
whatever's in front of him and then
other people are like you know you see
them just taking you know try to
minimize because it's it's challenging
or they like always have like a little
fruit bowl or like a salad because
they're like I can do this seven times
but like no we had a whole Thanksgiving
feast one of the things though that I
think is cool is you shot it on black
and white I think it's like the same way
they shot
um uh Stephen was just saying to me the
same way that uh uh darrenovsky shot pie
uh with the black and white 16
millimeter reversal footage
um so what was it like work because I
don't know how often you guys work with
film but not it's not often for a lot of
people so what was that like 15 years
ago it was filmed and it switched to
digital and then now I feel like I've
been doing a lot of stuff on film oh for
real yeah wait like when back then you
were doing a lot of film yeah yeah 2005.
and just I haven't been working that
long but what was it like for you guys
it's just
like uh Jason was saying there's certain
things you can't manipulate there's a
longer process
um what was that like tent where the
dude had his hands in there he was like
oh yeah yeah as we were shooting
um so it's just more than just like
hitting record and go you know
um but it looks stunning so it's all
it's all worth it and 16 million you
need a lot of light yeah a lot a lot of
hot light it's great when you're filming
outside in 120 degrees no they would
bring lights inside that were hotter
than 120 degrees Yeah it was it was
intense it's one of these plus lights
right I mean you know like I said
filmmaking you know it's very glamorous
you know so I definitely want to talk
about when you were making this did you
have any idea that you were going to be
part of Sundance because it's I mean
it's very cool to be here with the film
no I don't think we knew I think we kind
of had kept our fingers crossed in hopes
that we would be here
and we're here and it's my first
experience
um and it's just amazing and awesome to
be here
yeah
who's I know you've been here before
with Sundance but is have you been here
I'm
I've been here but like it was not a
movie I had it was like an award thing
oh I was gonna say you wanted to party I
get it oh no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
um so I I'm gonna do one more question I
can tell you enjoy talking right am I
yeah I was I'm just [__] around so my
thing though is when you're composing
and you're working on the music what
have are you using the similar software
to what you've been doing or how is it
Advanced as technology is advanced
um like the Symphonies are sick they
sound like real Symphonies orchestras
you know and all those sounds otherwise
I'm using the same stuff when the beat
side when I'm doing the Beats that's
traditionally what I do but when it
comes to the sounds and orchestral
sounds that sounds like a real Orchestra
now it doesn't sound like keyboard [__]
at all
how did how much back and forth uh went
on with the music on this I pretty much
nailed it like 80 the first time then
there was some details we had to dial in
sure but we got it yeah
um I definitely am curious if you guys
are gonna see any other movies while
you're here or are you sort of like in
and out of the festival yeah sadly I I
I'm in now pretty in and out but I I
like I definitely want to see everything
that I'm hearing about so I'm gonna just
go to the theaters are you hanging out
are you staying here no I mean when like
everything gets bought oh got it yeah oh
you're staying for the week you know
what I mean um well listen I I I'm gonna
stop here and just say that I'm
sincerely no [__] really looking
forward to seeing this movie and I will
see it while I'm here at Sundance and
really congratulations for being part of
the festival and I really wish you
nothing but the best thank you thank you